hello and welcome to a small clip from
our weekly game of thrones show gamespot
of Thrones for the whole episode make
sure to head over to youtube com
gamespot and we'll see you there all
right Dave trying to kick things off
with Sansa arriving at the ball this has
to be so frustrating it's frustrating to
watch okay admittedly yes but imagine
you've gone all this way like you've
escaped Ramsay to go to the wall to find
your brother and he's like sorry love
you just missed him he's just left fresh
tracks in the snow yeah but like instead
of following those I'm guessing this
could the silver lining of this could be
the start of a super team up between San
sir and Davos a dream team since then
I'll suck at Castle black yeah if the if
the wildlings don't go with John hmm
then chances are they may either go back
south and carry what they're doing but I
think this could be leading up to the
battle scene that we saw outside winds
phantom the trailers hmm so we see
Ramsay the heaven army mm-hmm which
makes sense now because like he's he's
now pledged himself to help against the
wildlings yeah he secured the umbers the
man delays and the car stuck exactly
especially after the gift of recon recon
so they could now be heading north to
fight the wildlings but that wildlings
with all speed moving south to find John
even now think of as a god and once he
know defend him and especially if if
Sansa turns up explains to Davos that
help me Ramsey's hunting me he was awful
all these horrible things he did to me
he might also be able to like get all
the men from Castle black and all the
wildlings on his side much south the
fight Ramsay maybe they'll meet the
middle so as frustrating as this is
gonna be for them just arriving as
John's left yeah the silver lining is
maybe this is the pre Luda bastard book
so you just think that it's it sucks
they've just missed each other but it
gives time for San sir and Davos to make
their dream team onions and lemon cakes
for it together forever buddy caught me
if you've always wanted and then they'll
go down a little bit John will just be
chillin bean I don't know what to do and
they'll be like well it's a mission for
your friend and then it all kicks
oh yes that's why I'm hoping for anyway
otherwise it's just frustration force
frustrations sake and Kate Marjorie's
back she's been gone for so long but we
finally got a glimpse of her yes we did
she's looking pretty worse for wear her
hair's kind of gross we see her in her
cell and she's finally being lifted up
by a guy who looks like the high Sparrow
it's a spiritual and it's it's a
symbolic thing of lifting her up raising
her up maybe she actually thinks she's
going to confess now and that's what
says he goes and tells Elenna she goes
Marjorie's going to confess in front the
whole city and alone and then it goes
can't let that happen for various
reasons it's embarrassing it makes the
Tyrells look bad and you know we don't
want to know what she's been up to she's
been up to things that need to stay
secret probably girls gonna have a
secrets oh yeah Ilona has loads and so
Elena goes yeah we can't do that and
Cersei surprising me says I agree so
buddy cop movie version too we don't
actually know what's gonna happen here
now Cersei looks like she's saying I
agree in that kind of smirky Cersei way
and that could either mean that she does
actually agree but only to get the
Tyrells on her side so that she can
fight the faith which is plausible or
she's saying like she's about to have
the mountain kill everyone in the room
and then kill Marjorie I guess also
possible I've seen in previous trailers
if I were called the Tyrell Army yes it
leaves certainly mace Tyrell in his
fancy garb mm-hmm this giant blue helmet
so this must be like part of Circe's
greater ploy to at least have some
numbers yes so somehow she's gonna stop
Marjorie confessing hopefully not with
murder because that means she won't
really have anyone on his side although
I do kind of want to see a murder sooner
or later the mountain hasn't really done
many important murders he smashed
someone's head that's about it um so we
know I think we know this sir she's
going to get the Tyrells onside we don't
know how she's going to do that exactly
but it's likely manipulation and maybe
murder of the high Sparrow somehow
sooner or later it's going to happen it
could be next episode and my love my
favorite character I am so glad he's
back little fingers back he can see him
with dear little sweet robin and his
minder basically it just looks a little
finger is it gonna do what little finger
does best that's not accents limitedly
but he says um Santa has escaped
Winterfell she won't be safe with the
Bolton's after her which sort of sort of
seems like it's his fault that she was
admittedly with the Bolton's so maybe I
want to say that little finger feels
remorse or guilt cuz I don't think that
it's possible for him to do that but he
doesn't have that path his brain he does
love Catelyn Stark a lot he does love
Sansa Stark a lot so it's interesting to
see if he's gonna catch are like
convince Robin to give his armies
because the veil is really well
protected it's real it's a great not
only is it great location but their
armies are really strong really well
equipped and trained so if he's gonna
offer the veils armies tus answers by
way of apology for snowball snow down
whatever you want to call it it also
means that Robin will take the fall and
that he can just do what he does best
and not not get any blaming snow get the
blame ball so he he wanted to be ward in
the north right that's one yeah he was
gearing up for he didn't ultimately get
it so it's a way of him for him to
easily get Ramsey out yeah you get Sansa
back maybe you sansom is gonna like give
anyone water the North I don't know a
woman can be not warden of the north she
can be um yeah she can be air now right
cuz she's the only one yeah but like
would she give that wardenship sir it's
Baelish what would she do instead she
would just take it and banish him right
give it to Davos systems like cool guy
he's used to ships he can't be stuck up
in the north will be sad he's gonna
fingers through and get frostbite only
on one hand yeah true
you